With rents for even the smallest quarters
exceeding the equivalent of $1000 monthly,
a relatively large number of working class
people in Asia’s largest cities have become,
essentially, homeless.
Rather than being completely destitute, as
many homeless are, a not inconsiderable number
of these individuals earn enough to otherwise
support themselves outside of being able to
afford housing.
To solve the problem of lack of funds for
more traditional accommodations, many have
turned to 24-hour establishments for a place
to spend the night and catch a few Zs, including,
in particular, McDonald’s and Manga cafes.
The McDonald’s crowd is particularly prevalent
in China and Hong Kong, where they are sometimes
called McRefugees or McSleepers; photographs
of people slumped over in booths or on table
tops, surrounded by the remains of their purchases,
abound.
Some overnight businesses seem to encourage
the practice – particularly as McSleepers
tend to be consistent customers who otherwise
cause no trouble.
As a McDonald’s Hong Kong representative
officially noted: “We welcome all walks
of life to visit our restaurants any time.”
Hong Kong is a particular difficult place
to find affordable housing, as between 2008
and 2015 prices have grown by 130%.
Today, according to Expatistan, rent for a
480 square foot studio costs between HK$22,867
and HK$15,150 (roughly $1900 and $3000) a
month.
In 2015, Hong Kong was estimated to have around
1,000 McRefugees, though it’s noted that
official government numbers here are likely
massively underestimating the extent of the
problem.
On that note, the working homeless situation
came to the forefront that year with reports
that a middle-aged woman lay dead in a McDonald’s
for seven hours before anyone bothered to
check on her; employees thought she was sleeping.
Tokyo has a similar issue with monthly rent
for a similarly small studio ranging from
¥96,000 to ¥185,000 (about $850-$1640).
However, the reports from Japan are ever so
slightly less disheartening, as it appears
that its working homeless have cobbled together
a somewhat more comfortable combination of
all night businesses in which to sleep.
In fact, as far back as 2007, it was reported
that approximately 5,400 Tokyo residents spent
at least half of their weeks staying in internet
cafes; more recently, Manga Cafes (so named
due to the addition of extensive manga libraries
on the premises) have become very popular.
More comfortable than McDonald’s, at least,
customers at manga cafes enjoy a private booth
with a computer, unlimited internet, access
to a DVD and manga library and a reclining,
office-style chair.
Soft drinks are usually provided for free,
while food (generally of the greasy variety)
is available to purchase at modest prices.
For reference here, the fee for a cubicle
in one of these establishments generally ranges
from around ¥1400 to ¥2400 ($12-$21) for
up to 12 hours.
capsule hotelAs you can imagine, however,
sleeping in such accommodations isn’t exactly
the most comfortable thing in the world and
chronic back pain tends to be the name of
the game for many of these individuals.
For those who can splurge on occasion, however,
to round out their weeks, some of these cyber-homeless
rely on other reasonably priced all night
services for a slightly more restful night’s
sleep, such as capsule hotels.
Not for the claustrophobic, for the equivalent
of about ¥3000 to ¥6000 (roughly $25-$50)
a night, at a capsule hotel the lodger receives
an encapsulate bunk bed along with access
to communal locker rooms and bathing facilities.
Another option Tokyo’s working homeless
sometimes turn to are public baths, which
can cost anywhere from a few hundred to a
few thousand yen a night (roughly a
few dollars to $40).